[Aplausos]
quiero empezar diciendo que tengo más de
20 años de experiencia manejando equipos
de alto rendimiento
que me he llevado en esos 20 años
el factor humano es el elemento más
difícil de cualquier estructura
organizacional es un elemento variable
es un elemento volátil es un elemento en
que es totalmente impredecible y tú
tienes que ser cambiante ante ese factor
sin embargo ustedes ven esa pantalla y
detrás en esa pantalla y detrás usted es
una persona
claramente soy yo y la vez mirando a lo
lejos esa mirada que ustedes ven ahí en
una mirada que dice visión que dice
planificación que dice organización
mi esposa está aquí conmigo y esas
palabras que yo dije estoy seguro que
identifican a esta persona cabeza un
poquito complejo de vivir con él porque
es cuadrado es planificado es visionario
sin embargo para tener éxito en la vida
tú necesitas tener un alter ego
esa persona que te ven ahí es la misma
es la misma sin embargo para tu poder
ser exitoso en el trayecto tú necesitas
tener la visión la planificación la
organización junto con la toma de
decisiones los riesgos pensar fuera de
la caja es como el doctor jekyll and el
doctor jaén todo aquel que conoce
aquella historia tú tienes que tener tu
doctor ya que en el momento y tu doctor
hi en otros
como soy muy apasionado
muchas veces trato de encontrarme a mí
mismo
la mejor forma que uso es esa votar mi
adrenalina con las motocicletas [ __ ]
kilómetros como decimos nosotros cuando
tengo tiempo pues trato de tomarme un
tiempo de esparcimiento
para mí
una vez se me presenta una oportunidad
de recorrer los eeuu completo
solo en un retiro espiritual en mi
motocicleta harley davis pero no quise
hacerlo solo quise aprovechar esos 14
días que lo iba a hacer pero al final
quería juntarme con mi esposa en unas
merecidas vacaciones aquí en las vegas
todo el mundo quiere ir a las vegas y yo
dije dejemos que mi esposa se quede aquí
en santo domingo en la república
dominicana mientras los 14 días antes
estoy aventurando por todos los estados
unidos y luego toparme con ella
cualquiera que vio mi planificación del
viaje pensaba que el objetivo de mi
viaje era ir al final a las vegas' a
pasarme una semana con mi esposa jugando
en los casinos y divirtiéndonos en esa
gran ciudad como todo el mundo hace sin
embargo me enseñó la vida el elemento
humano me enseñó que el trayecto es lo
más importante me cambió la vida y le
voy a hacer la anécdota ahora yo rente a
una salida división en ohio
mi intención era devolverla en la costa
oeste de los eeuu cuando reventó la
harley en nueva york
salvo oeste franco y mi primera parada
fue una pequeña villa llamada amis
village
en esa villa como todos conocen la
cultura
era cerrada y enclaustrada en el siglo
18 esa cultura no conoce los famosos
adelantos técnicos que hablábamos
anteriormente en nuestra expliqué la
anterior no conocen lo que es una nevera
no conocen lo que es un microondas viven
de la tierra viven de su religión y de
su comunidad pues yo me paro ahí un día
y medio luego de haber salido nueva york
me paro en esa villa
con la intención de entrar a un pequeño
supermercado que me llamó la atención
donde vendían panes trigos hay ética
todo muy orgánico todo muy de las
tierras todo muy hecho por ellos cuando
le tengo mi hallyday son frente a este a
este local veo sentado en el frente a
una familia pequeña veo a una niña de 7
años veo a un papá y una mamá que
atendía en el mostrador
pues yo entro saludo no me saludan los
amish no interactúan ese elemento humano
es complejo en su cultura no interactúan
y entró pero que estaba con una chamarra
de cuero y una bandana de cuero como
ustedes vieron en la foto yo andaba
vestido como hold y no como de vivar
cuando yo entro los niños son niños no
importa la cultura y yo empiezo a
caminar los pasillos mirando que me voy
a llevar y yo veía que la niña pequeña
iba detrás de mí
y yo seguía mirando y yo la había detrás
y yo nunca pensé que una niña me iba a
interactuar conmigo se me acerca y me
ala la chaqueta y me dice en un perfecto
inglés
cuando yo oigo la pregunta
inmediatamente yo entendí el concepto
seguro esa niña de 7 años que ustedes
saben esa foto es real y ese dinero que
está ahí en medio porque no pueden
tarjeta de crédito
y
el contexto yo lo entendí ella dijo
nunca en mi vida había visto una persona
de una etnia diferente me pregunta y yo
sabiendo que la respuesta que yo le iba
a dar no la iba a entender aunque no son
brutos son muy inteligentes pero viven
en su claustro
yo le dije mira tratando de ser lo más
genérico posible mira yo soy de una
pequeña isla en el caribe no mencionó el
hombre no mencionó nada porque no va a
saberlo
ella me mira hace un silencio lo sujetó
solito y la pestaña plantita y me dice
señor
y en su isla
todos son negros con usted
entendí la pregunta me la encontré
graciosa en su vida ella había visto una
etnia diferente lógico esta que ni soy
rubio y tengo los ojos azules yo le
contesté
sí
y más
no me entendió pero con eso quise
dejarle dicho a ella que la vida tiene
varios pintas razas variopintas culturas
por eso acá vemos que la cultura al
estilo de vida y las creencias en el
factor humano en ese elemento de la
tabla periódica son la columna vertebral
del pensamiento de las comunidades
no me quedo ahí yo tengo todavía dos
días de viajes largos todavía voy por
quince de mi trayecto y sigo ese
trayecto que venga usted de aquí
seis días después aproximadamente yo
estoy en la frontera con nebraska
ya vengo con varias horas encima de mi
harley davison seis o siete horas sin
parar dándole a la salida visión y ya
decidido que es el momento de tomar un
descanso señores yo no iba con ningún
tipo de planificación tenía un
presupuesto tenía una ruta de viaje que
yo me iba a parar en el primer hotel que
viene en las carreteras de acuerdo a la
ruta que estaba se basada todo francas
de este a oeste y cuando veo un hotelito
en la frontera que decía vacancy es
parqueo mijal desmontó me fundo y lo
primero que veo en el mostrador
no baile
parece que en ese hotel hito no
permitían motociclistas
trate de convencer dominicano al fin
trate de convencer a la persona del
mostrador
que yo no era uno de esos bikers malos
que yo no era un delincuente que yo lo
que estaban haciendo una aventura por
todos los estados unidos y sus únicas
palabras eran know biker
entendí en ese momento que el elemento
humano
se deja influenciar por los estereotipos
yo era un estereotipo en ese momento que
él consideraba que no era de su agrado o
del agrado de esa zona central de los
eeuu que ustedes saben que es bastante
conservador
cuando trató de convencer lo que dice no
mira
hay otro hotel 50 millas más adelante
son las 7 de la noche con una
temperatura de wind chill de 5 grados
ya oscureciendo y en donde las
carreteras están llenas de serpientes de
gatos salvajes y de arañas gigantes como
yo nunca la había visto pues no me quedó
otro remedio que agarrar 50 millas más
adelante hora y media después y logré
llegar a un hotelito ya saliendo de
nebraska que si puedes pasar la noche
sigo mi viaje
ya está veis
cruzando los eeuu y tres días cuatro
días después aproximadamente pues llegó
ayuda en yuta me doy cuenta
recuérdense que yo tenía un calendario
de viaje muy informal pero un calendario
de viaje me doy cuenta en ese punto eso
es una foto real donde yo estoy en la
encrucijada que les voy a contar me doy
cuenta en ese punto
que faltan tres días para que mi esposa
salga de república dominicana en un
avión a la conexión por aquí no se
quiera por charlotte o por lo por miami
hacia las vegas
yo estoy tres días de lanzado me quedo y
digo ok
si me voy a las vegas'
no tengo el dinero en mi presupuesto de
pasarme tres días en una ciudad tan cara
esperando a mi esposa
déjame yo pensar bien y no gastar este
dinero y ver qué hago esos tres días en
ese punto había una bifurcación que era
o bajaba las vegas' los ven ahí y yo en
estar ahí
ocho horas como mucho o seguía mi
aventura que me faltaban tres días hacia
nevada y decidí déjame hacer algo que yo
siempre he querido hacer voy a cruzar el
desierto de nevada
esto es una decisión en el momento
calculada con esos riesgos calculados
que lo toman cuando decidió hacerlo
decido pero tengo que echar gasolina y
me paro en una estación de gasolina y
adivinen lo que encontré en la estación
de gasolina
ese letrero que dice próxima estación a
200 millas única estación a 200 millas
population 0
cuando yo no estaba en que yo de bueno
yo soy capaz 200 millas no hay problema
cuando ya no están que miro el marcador
de la harley y la independencia de
kilometraje me dice su hija le tiene
capacidad de recorrer 175 millas
bueno en ese momento
tuve que trazar una estrategia
hay que seguir hacia adelante
no hay un solo ser humano en esa
carretera que usted venga y hasta llegar
a nevada del otro lado ajeno a cárcel
city
he decidido hacer una estrategia de
viajes digo si estás 200 millas la mitad
del recorrido yo lo hago a una velocidad
promedio por encima de lo permitido por
la ley
total no hay nadie ahí yo podría hacerlo
y la segunda mitad ya con medio tanque
puede ser una velocidad muy prudente
para ahorrar gasolina pues decidí
aventurarme y la mitad del recorrido
100 110 millas por hora una velocidad
prudente rápida pero la otra lo hice muy
despacio y efectivamente cuando estoy
saliendo de esa gran recta del desierto
de nevada pues prende el bombillo de la
reserva de la sal y al minuto una
estación de gasolina ello perfecto me
salió como estaba pensando
cuando llegó esa estación de gasolina
recargo gasolina recargo energías digo
ya es hora de buscar otro delito
recuérdese que no tenía planificado
donde dormir era el que encontraba pero
veo una valla gigante un billboard
grande que decía bienvenido a la reserva
indígena de gua yo
yo no sabía que lo que les voy a contar
ahora cambiaría mi vida
cuando yo veo la lava ya que eso mirar
muchos cano pis de esas casitas donde
viven los indígenas pero muchos de
muchos colores rojos negro en toda la
lateral y yo digo pero mira cómo viven
las personas y veo un
un localcito de madera bien trabajado en
madera un poquito lo lejos que decía
bacán sí de nuevo y yo digo
guau hotel cuando entro no era un hotel
en una estancia de una reserva indígena
si vas a dormir ahí iba a dormir en los
k no pis de los indígenas pues esta
anécdota me cambió la vida yo entro
y me sale una señora de unos 60 años
aproximadamente indígena
roja ella
con un atuendo guau jonathan de gua yo
es ese gran poncho de colores de cuadros
que usan los indígenas con plumas acá es
ser su atuendo normal y empezamos a
hacer la transacción de quedarme una
noche ahí cuando ella me dice el monto
que yo debo pagar por esa noche pues
claro que sí saco mi bulto en lo que
estoy buscando mi tarjetero para sacar
mi tarjeta de crédito pues pongo un
porta cigarros que yo tengo
los que me conocen saben que yo soy un
amante del puro dominicano y del cigarro
dominicano y siempre ando con ellos no
aprovechen no desaprovecha oportunidad
de fumar me el puro dominicano pues lo
pongo en el mostrador y cuando yo pongo
ese ese porta cigarro en el mostrador la
señora le cambió la cara
se puso blanca y me dijo usted fuma
cuando me digo eso casi las 8 de la
noche no se veía una lucecita boyata
ocurrió yo no me va a dejar dormir aquí
qué mala suerte le digo yo sí
en ese momento y sin mediar palabras
ella dijo dos veces mirando hacia atrás
del montador that's all alí
that's all alí
y ahí sale del sol al y un señor de 62
de unos 70 y algo años con el pelo largo
tipo la película de los indios con el
pelo largo blanco látex roja jugada
rústico con unas manos que parecían
mascotas de que ella
y me hace la misma pregunta usted fuma
y yo le hago la yo le digo la misma
respuesta le digo si yo soy dominicano
me gusta el puro cuando ese señor oyó
que yo era amante del puro saco su pipa
su pipa tradicional guayo y me dice mi
nombre es that's all al y tercero hijo
del toro sentado de las estrellas
famosas
yo soy el jefe de la reserva y de la
tribu guay dónde nevada usted hoy es mi
invitado de honor usted hoy no paga y se
fuma la pipa de la paz conmigo e
intercambiarla por sus cigarros señores
yo me pasé la mejor noche de mi vida con
la esposa los hijos la familia y el jefe
indio solari contándome de las historias
de cuando los indígenas llegaron de sus
ancestros hasta las 4 de la mañana en
pleno gran cañón sin una nubecita y las
estrellas para mí eso cambió mi vida
hasta hoy that's all ally y yo tenemos
comunicación y de vez en cuando le mando
su cajita de puro haya nevada
al otro día pues ya tenía que concluir
mi viaje ya mi esposa claudia aquí
presente iba a estar en las vegas'
al otro día pero yo aprendo que la
cultura el estilo de vida y las
creencias al igual que los amish
recuerden seguir días atrás cuando
hablamos de los años igual que los años
determinan que el elemento humano es el
factor que cambia todo el proceso
estamos hablando del mismo país estamos
hablando de la misma zona con culturas
totalmente diferente pues sigo mi camino
y un chelín ya estoy llegando a las
vegas llega es una foto tradicional de
la vega todo el mundo es decir una foto
como un paraguayo en la
para decir que fue las vegas pues yo me
tiro esa foto con mi esposa y le hago
unas anécdotas a ella de lo que yo había
vivido el día anterior en la tribu ahí
ustedes la vieron en la foto en el
slavia anterior y es porque ella me
convenció
de que invirtiéramos un día de nuestras
vacaciones en devolverse conmigo para
conocer a esa famosa familia que me
había cambiado en mi abogado tal mundo
en mi parecer en la humanidad
esto se oye muy bonito todo esto que
acabo de contar es real tengo a mi
esposa y que no me deja mentir pero
vamos a aterrizar lo un poquito la vida
no es tanta aventura la vida no es tanto
interiorizar lo que uno siente la vida
es práctica y yo quise poner ese mismo
recorrido que ustedes ven ahí en el mapa
de los eeuu sobre una hoja de cálculo
en lo que día a día nosotros hacemos
como seres humanos nosotros necesitamos
analizar una situación
cuando yo salí de nueva yor analice mi
situación pero no solamente tú analizas
tu situación tú debes definir un
objetivo específico en la definición de
mis objetivos no está va a vivir la
mayor aventura de mi vida
todo el mundo pensó que mi objetivo era
llegar a las vegas pero las personas
deben definir sus objetivos
si tú no elabora estrategias y planes de
acción no son las mismas cosas las
estrategias te dicen que hacer los
planes de acción te dicen cómo hacerlo
si tú no haces esas dos cosas no vas a
llegar a ningún sitio
los recursos ustedes se recuerdan que lo
que me hizo vivir la mejor experiencia
de mi vida fue la falta de dinero no
tenía dinero para quedarme tres días en
las vegas y prefería hacer seguir
aventurando hasta conocer esa tribuna yo
con los recursos que tenían ustedes de
evaluar en su vida de qué y con qué
cuenta para realizar cualquier cosa y al
final
pues estar midiendo lo que estás
viviendo estar midiendo lo que está
pasando estar midiendo tu vida
quiero dejar para finalizar
tres claves son mías
tres claves que yo considero
qué son
parte del éxito del elemento humano
primero
paradoja
el factor humano y la vida es un
misterio
invierta tiempo olvide se ejecutó no
logro entender viva 2 humor ría se ata
de usted mismo tenga siempre una sonrisa
en la cara sea un people person y así
cambio no se quede quieto si se queda
quieto se muere muévase señores feliz
selector del trayecto gracias por
escucharme